[Music]
and welcome back to the quest crew
podcast where we are lucky enough to
have lovely guests here thank you guys
for coming cast of jk news
thank you for having us you guys
couldn't get anybody else couldn't get
anyone else actually it's um it's we
only have one jk member here which is
nick because it's joe from tiger belly
oh right anthony from kenja's and bar
from barbell brigade and i'm
representing jk news
thank you i am the resident jk news guys
did you know you were the jk embassy
that's the knicks official is it the
lionheart academy no it's nte training
baby that's what's up oh nickname your
training why did you grab my harmony nte
training
the year yeah why you never talk about
this [ __ ] i'm jk you're on my arm when
you said that just because you know i'm
just a little nervous example so he's
trying to give us a little he hates
promoting himself this is so funny what
do you think that is pretty young i
think that is about me let's talk about
it he hates compliments too that he's
doing a good job he can't stand we
should give him more wake up sharon all
right guys so welcome to the quest crew
podcast
counting your calories with jujitsu
welcome back hawk this is the first time
having you here with uh your buddy ryan
as the official host now we're stealing
him away from your crew as well as we
have this other dancer here that you're
very familiar with
from six
you know like on the show yeah anthony
gets like made fun of a lot but i always
like to rational in my head it's because
everywhere else other than this room
yeah he's like the coolest see we have
to balance it out yeah yeah he's
probably one of the most distinguished
decorated half to balance the industry
and he's still working that's the
difference we're all not really working
and the
weird thing is he likes coming here too
anthony he's so cool he's like brad pitt
on the outside and he comes in here and
he's bobby lee all of a sudden it's kind
of like i think it's kind of like when
people go to like dominatrixes
it's like a ceo that likes to hire a
hooker that drips candle wax on their
ass
wait so when are you guys going to start
handcuffing anthony during these podcast
patreon that's my picture oh okay if
this was hawks the guest today
yeah he's gonna be administering the
ball gag this episode for you
yeah [ __ ] i have a question when you
first met anthony lee what was your
first impression
so that's why we wanna hear what he has
to say
yes when was the first time i didn't
he's like not memorable not memorable at
all
no well i have a terrible memory did you
meet up backstage crying you know what
we were [ __ ] doing
we were [ __ ] at a party doing this
for like half an hour we were [ __ ] at
a party we were
like what is this wait what is this
first time you met we were doing this
for like half an hour what is this
can you explain he's he's gonna say it
in a nice accident so it understands
it's just that's weird how do you expect
to win anything like that
that's crazy
no we were talking about a couple months
ago but it's this you know you have
different techniques and dance and um
there's one called fixed point uh it's
like more like an animation popping
technique and i think at the time it was
kind of new to it so we were just
practicing it and we found out that
i guess um
that was whack i had introduced it to
mike or something and it was
yeah it was such a weird surprise did
anybody master it was like did it get
passed around and there was one person
no you're dude you guys are fix pointers
okay so the idea the idea i'll give a
basic idea but the funny thing about it
is like uh we were learning how to
practice
like if you have one fixed point then
anything that you move that one point
stays fixed right that's the idea of it
so even if you take your finger away
from it and you put your fixed point now
here you should still be able to create
the same illusion right so that's the
concept but the funnier concept is that
you're at a [ __ ] party in la and
you're sitting in a corner of room while
everyone else is socializing a drink
with hot [ __ ] and [ __ ] you're just
sitting there like this for like half an
hour like
but the funny thing is whenever we
started touring his quest and we would
do club shows and stuff same thing i
would be just sitting down doing that it
would be like the craziest party and
then you would just kind of see is that
hot and he's like in a vip booth that's
deserted way in the [ __ ] corner and
he's just going
do you know what that's like that's like
that's like can when we're doing when
we're going on our walks i just see can
like i don't know if this is the term
but he's just voguing like this
but he's smoking 100 percent corrective
yeah yeah he's voguing right you know
that's that's the behind the curtain of
being an artist though because when you
see an artist perform right it's so
[ __ ] cool it's so insane but behind
like rappers are like sketches elephant
velvet
sullivan you know what it's so not cool
that's not that's like the whackest [ __ ]
ever but then when you come out oh
[ __ ] drink so [ __ ] cool or
whatever
but behind the scenes [ __ ] the garage
collage
this might be this might be a hot take
but i don't think rappers do that
that's their version of [ __ ]
y'all dude elephant velophant dude
his second try
garage
yeah yeah yeah when it's collage dude
stop rapping that's your best
rappers don't do that man yeah crazy
rhyme words they gotta work on their
juices
and they're not using it they're not
using any help he's trying to they're
just going in the corner they're just
like
there's no dictionary it sounds like
this there's so many tools
so that's basically how we met
artists
that was 2005. substitute this for our
penises
and it's not a hat it's both like this
[Laughter]
it's not touching it's not touching it's
not even a sword fight it's a [ __ ]
magnetic dick energy yeah yeah so for
anyone who doesn't know me and hawk have
been dancing together since 2000
probably four
holy [ __ ] wow eighteen years
got done yeah and then we've been
dancing against anthony for even longer
than that yeah we're like for like 58
years
yeah from our past lives
all right we'll do this let's do this so
we have representatives from the quest
crew yeah and we have a representative
from the kinshas
if you were going to draft the remaining
members in this room to be on your quest
crew members
who would you pick and why why would you
pick me to be on the quest and why would
you pick me to be on the kingdom fight
throw voguer and he said velophan
fight for every single one of them
on your crew and why
would joe be more on the question if
bart was on quest i'm already first pick
i know yeah
i know we would i will be on quest we
would have better rhymes
elephant and developer there if you were
there we would just be way more fit
but then we wouldn't be able to say who
helped us because he doesn't like being
told that he's good at it
join the crew and never tell anyone he
was a part of the crew and also not even
talk good about the crew yeah and he'll
also be like uh yeah i'm gonna go to
rehearsal oh i'm just kidding i got to
be with my wife
that's [ __ ] nick dude i don't know
the [ __ ] you're talking about dude [ __ ]
be like hey what time is dance rehearsal
all right i'll be there oh wait i
actually have to train david so i'll see
you guys later
i'm still a trainer
which side will toby on i don't know
i mean i've been wanting to be a kinja
for quite some time you know but then
like i was never invited so yeah
until now
how much does it cost to be in
kindergarten yeah six hundred dollars a
month
a week
steals that's a steal right
wait it costs to be in a dance crew i'm
too cheap for that [ __ ]
i think it's like church and it's 500.
i thought it's like church well i guess
you have to give money in the offering
but then it's like suggested you know oh
yeah this is also suggest
now you guys have to fight for bart
i don't think anyone is no no you guys
have to pick up something from barbara
hey we actually pay you to be in jk
that's different man that's not fair
do you gotta pay to beat a guy wrong you
got it all wrong i think that's why this
show's going down
that's what we should do start charging
we need to charge people like you charge
people for barbell brigade right yeah
when they come that makes sense do we
gotta sell the seats oh my god how much
how much does it cost to be in quest
if it's cheaper than kendra's i mean
your life your whole reputation i'm in
dude time i'm an expectation so it's
free all this plans you had for life as
a straight man
throw that away yep you'll remember
[Laughter]
yeah i don't know i'm too masculine for
that yeah
yeah i think you're more of a kendra
dude yeah cages are like the pinnacle of
masculinity you know what though i think
like
dance wise dance style wise quest crew
has too much break dancing and i'm not
ready to break my bones it's all an
illusion
yeah yeah if you really look closely
it's just this with their bodies
so like we've professionally figured out
how to look like we're doing more than
we are yeah to the point where we'll
come off stage and each member will get
the wrong compliment like a personal
goal yeah
dude you were flipping all around like
crazy you're awesome man
other guy
because he did the he did the jump over
you guys yeah if you really look at any
of our shows he's the only one really
doing flips him and rudy
everyone else is just kind of going
underneath them i have a question for
you you're doing [ __ ] barely my flip i
do like one flip and then hirano does
the one leg thing yeah i'm not really
doing but then the thing is at the end
of the show everyone thinks everyone had
an equal part in everything this seems
so acrobatic yeah well oh also you do
the thing where you land on your back
that's kind of a flip it's like a hassle
florida you see you guys ages ago at the
[ __ ] long beach convention center
1984
the day i was born
just barely sticking out looking at a
show
oh [ __ ] there was someone in your joey
and they always got a reaction because
they did this super gay move where they
touched their toes and then rolled up
slowly oh that's probably that's victory
that was his move
yeah i saw that and i was like man
that's a real
gay clue
no like i was like what's coming up the
real yeah that's a really cool move hey
uh speaking of speaking of gay so
everybody really really loves your
accent how do you do a gay british
accent
it starts gay
it's your job to straighten it out queen
like she divvies out that role there
ever oh
so it starts you have to get it
it starts flamboyant yeah what does a
flamboyant british accent sound like
the baby the baby comes out and goes
what looks milk please
that's your dad you idiot
i'd like to have milk of the penis
right that's british that's a bye baby
because you got to be gay
they drink their tea with me nobody's
gonna say that like
it's just that's so disturbing well they
are smaller yeah they're more articulate
they're more articulate than americans i
think yeah i i love it though when i
asked the question when i'm like i have
no idea what's funny it's like after
knowing him for this many years i've
heard him have to explain his accent so
many times like that's the first thing
people say when they meet him they're
like why do you talk like that yeah why
do you talk like that yeah like he's
choosing chinese way
you're supposed to talk like that
why don't you talk like this one why are
you not talking like this
who's that i don't know
that would be so funny for what your
asian accent's very unusual did the
asian accent they're like why are you
not talking like this one
because that's what it felt like they
were doing aquafina
she's like dude i'm from new york and
they're like why don't you talk like
this
who said that like the people they're
like everyone that's criticizing like
the reporters and [ __ ] no because she
like sounds hella urban and they're like
no you're appropriating yeah yeah but
it's like she's like what am i supposed
to sound like
we can can you do an american accent
i've gotten this so many times too oh
yeah you gotta give him a sentence
though yeah yeah and i'll do a really
bad job with it okay it's probably
better now uh say um uh my name
everybody calls me mcbee
or or i'm colonel john mcburney yeah
yeah i am colonel i'm colonel john
mcburney i'm colonel with john mcburney
colonel john mcqueen no that's that's
your american accent but
try to get more clint eastwood with it
i'd say old enough for kisses yeah
okay so i tried like a western old
enough for kisses
oh enough for kissing oh that's good
that was really good it's the context
maybe it depends yeah it sets you up
better that's pretty good that's pretty
good so like you know party being in
quest crew i feel like you guys getting
some fun shenanigans so the funny thing
is that like back in the day whenever
when he was like kind of new here
uh
and then after meeting him people go to
me and then go why is that guy he has an
english accent i would say he just he
just does that
it doesn't help when when we go to a
restaurant or a cafe and that's what
they say to the the waiter
and then they just look at me as if i'm
joking the whole time so
we leave with them thinking that and i'm
just an [ __ ] at that point
committed talking to him and he's like
talking normally they're looking at them
like oh they're like okay okay they're
like it's freaking it makes it worse
when i try to explain too because
they're like oh wow you're really
committed but well it's got the
backstory too wow yeah because the story
is actually naturally complex so it
sounds like he's just freestyling it
if they think you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah you're a total [ __ ] other one so
the point that i've like this happened
so many times when like when they say
that i'm like yeah yeah sure that's you
know and it doesn't help that we live in
l.a because they're probably like
[ __ ] actors
you know what you should do you should
ham it up even more and do like a crazy
even more stereotypical british accent
and then just see if that like eggs them
on a little bit but you know what's
crazy is that for the longest time i
would think why would anyone do that you
know that's just so stupid that's mental
illness until i actually met someone
that
that did it and then it was really
confusing to me well
all the time yeah even though that's not
where they're from but what's the
rationale for that though
i i don't i are you cool with this
person
i don't know him that way well it's like
it's almost like i manifested that
because i used to say that i would as a
joke i would just go yeah he just done
that for attention to be cute and then
late years later we meet a guy who's
doing it probably for the same reason
for sure for that and i was like oh just
to like but i was amused that someone
would actually do that was there
accurate though
i wouldn't know he was doing an
australian accent oh was it for fun or
was it i guess like what if you do a
scouse accent the [ __ ] is scout
like that like that's all i got can you
do it
i'll just say the actual way
can you do it what's that
um
accent
what's your what's your is your action
southern what is it
i don't someone told me you sound posh
yeah i'm well because i grew up in
oxford so oh yeah
maybe in comparison
that's not one of the dictionaries
you know oxford yeah that's high class
it doesn't sound like a university
that's for sure was it remember we were
in the philippines and we were ordering
food and you told me to act like i don't
speak english
i was trying to act like i was filipino
and then they were like
you [ __ ] speak english
can you speak
tagalog no i can't your guys's crew
sounds fun because you're when you talk
about your crew it's just problems
it's like you didn't mess each other up
oh don't speak english
can you tell us what you were thinking
about that roe v wade thing just before
the camera
wait we're trying to keep this channel
dude oh yeah my bad this is like early
maybe like earlier earlier 2000s we used
to do this thing called gradual gay
where if you were gradual
oh you're in food at a restaurant yeah
you have to get through your whole order
start really straight and by the end of
your order you have to sound super
flammable like the stereotypical
flamboyant you have to do it in this
graph line
do you start macho macho
yeah they'll be like
yeah
welcome jack in the box all right check
this out
all right check this out i want some
fries hey listen boss make them curly
and then for the burger
you know put on sourdough
maybe a little cheese
do it without laughing
yeah i gotta do it like i'm so stupid
who's the best at that i don't know
probably because i'm gay
the guy better be the best the guy
taking the order because it's so gradual
it's like oh okay okay okay and then at
the end it's like hang on a second you
have to like hide it like what just
happened you're gonna be so gradual you
pull up to the window and you're like i
thank you
oh can you give me some more extra
ketchup please
it resets every time every window every
time every window but that's like a five
second exchange i know the credit card
it has to be big it's not gradual
anymore so you'd rather be a crew that
does stuff like that rather than he's
more natural to his personality
complaining and [ __ ]
wait what kind of complaints has you
have you heard from always complaining
about something
it keeps going it's very macho take
did you get lean program working it
doesn't look like it
yeah attacking [ __ ] dude it's literally
like would you rather be in the hugely
successful company or just have a ton of
fun
to get nothing is that a backhanded
i mean you guys heard it here first can
just have no fun
no fun
they're hugely successful super
that's why their outfits are so dark and
sad
and they cover their frowns sad they
cover their frown
purple and flamboyant happy masks are
crying because we're at the end of the
order yeah
yeah yeah we're at the beginning of the
world yeah
we're already ordering the sauces on our
side yeah
you